[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام انا طاهر البركه
احييكم وهذه هي العربيه 360 حيث الخبر من
كل زواياه ومن جميع جوانبه
[موسيقى]
اوكرانيا وتجمعهم على ضروره تفادي اندلاع
حرب عالميه
القصف على اوكرانيا يطالو كهرباء مولدوفا
تضرر خط كهرباء رئيس يتسبب بظلام في انحاء
البلاد
النووي تقريبا وتعلن اللامحادثات جاريه
معها حاليا
وفي العربيه 360 ايضا
مسكاه يفتح جبهه جديده على تويتر ويعلن عن
اقاله موظف عبر تغريده مباشره على المنصه
[موسيقى]
بعد افتتاح اندونيسيا اليوم قمه مجموعه
العشرين المنعقده في بالي كشفت ملامح
البيان الختامي للقمه مواقف اغلبيه الدول
الاعضاء وروما الانقسام بشان ادانه
العمليه العسكريه الروسيه برزتفاق على
وجوب تفادي اندلاع حرب عالميه بارده اخرى
انطلاقا من الحرب في اوكرانيا فيما اكدت
معظم البلدان المشاركه ان الحرب
الاوكرانيه تسببت بمعاناه بشريه هائله
وفاقمه الهشاشه التي يعاني منها الاقتصاد
العالميه في الاساس
اذا رويترز تتحدث عن سقوط صواريخ روسيه في
بولندا قتلت شخصين
والاخبار من بولندا تتحدث عن اجتماع عاجل
للحكومه ولجنه الامن القومي والدفاع بعد
سقوط صواريخ روسيه هذا مهم جدا لانه يعني
تمدد الحرب الى دوله هي بولندا قد يهوب
انيتو لمساعدتها في هذا المجال لانه يعتبر
همم تغير في مسار الحرب
وسنسمع من المسؤولين الفوللنديين قريبا
بعد هذا الاجتماع كيف سيكون عليه الموقف
اضافه الى مواقف الدول الغربيه دول العالم
فيما يتعلق بتمدد هذا الصراع الى اراضي
بولندا يبدو ان العالم او غالبيه العالم
غير راض عن حرب روسيا على جارتها الغربيه
اوكرانيا وهذا ما اتضح من بيان قمه مجموعه
العشرين المنعقده في بالي الاندونيسيه
هناك في بالي بدا طعمها اكبر الاقتصادات
في العالم بداوا مستعدين لايصال رساله
قويه بشان اداره الحرب الروسيه على
اوكرانيا المستمره منذ 9 اشهر والتي حملت
دمار كبيرا وعكرت صفوه الاقتصاد العالمي
كرر قاده مجموعه العشرين في مسوده بيانهم
ادانه الامم المتحده للحرب على اوكرانيا
لكن مع الاعتراف بوجود وجوهات نظر مختلفه
بين اعضاء التكتل الاقتصادي الكبير صيغه
البيان بدقه لمراعاه التوترات السائده في
القمه التي تضم روسيا والصين والتحدي الذي
تواجهه الولايات المتحده وحلفائها لعزل
حكومه الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتن لماذا
نقول التوترات لان بعض الدول تسعى الى
تجنب التورط في الصراع بين القوه الكبرى
خصوصا حلفاء موسكو لكن
لم يعجبكم
زملاؤنا في الغرب حاولوت السيسي الاعلان
المشترك وادانه روسيا بالانابه عن جميع
دول مجموعه العشرين بالرغم من ان الموضوع
خارج جدول اعمال المجموعه نعم هناك حرب في
اوكرانيا الغرب بداها وكان يحضر لها منذ
سنوات وان كان يحاول القاء اللون على
روسيا بسبب فشله في التوصل الى اتفاق
المشترك بشان اعلان مجموعه العشرين هذا
يعني ان الغرب لم ينجح
مسوده البيان نددت باشد العبارات بما
اثبته عدوان روسيا الاتحاديه وطالبت
بانسحابها الكامل وغير المشروط من اراضي
اوكرانيا مع التاكيد على اختلاف وجوهات
النظر بشان الوضع والعقوبات ضد روسيا
واعتبرت مسوده بيان القمه ان مجموعه
العشرين ليست منصه لحل المشكلات الامنيه
مع تاكيد الرئيس الاندونيسي جوبويدودو انه
ان لم تنتهي الحرب فسيكون من الصعب على
العالم المضيق قدما في القمه انضم رئيس
الاوكراني الى نظيره الامريكي في محاوله
لاقناع قاده المجموعه باتخاذ المزيد من
الخطوات لعزل روسيا دبلوماسيه واقتصاديا
وحددا 10 شروط لانهاء الصراع منها انسحاب
كامل للقوات الروسيه واستعاده اوكرانيا
كامله السيطره على اراضيها متحدثا بعد
ايام على استعاده بلاده مدينه خرسان
الاستراتيجيه
من القوات الروسيه
[موسيقى]
اريد ان تنتهي هذه الحرب الروسيه
العدوانيه بشكل عادل وعلى اساس ميثاق
الامم المتحده والقانون الدولي لن نسمح
لروسيا ان تنتظر انتائها وتحشد قواتها ثم
تبدا سلسله جديده من الارهاب وزعزعه
الاستقرار العالمي انا مقتنع الان انه
الوقت الذي يجب ويمكن فيه وقف الحرب
الروسيه المدره
في القمه التقى بيضا برئيس الوزراء الهندي
الذي يعتبر تعامله مهما في تامين حد اقصى
تسعى الولايات المتحده لفرضه على سعر
النفط الروسيه لتقليل ارباح موسكو التي
تستثمرها في قاعدتها الدفاعيه اما الحليف
الاخر الصين فامتنع مسؤولها عن اتقاد
الحرب الروسيه علنا رغم تجنب بكين دعم
الروس على ايضا فلم تزودهم باسلحه على
سبيل المثال الرئيس الامريكي قال خلال
اجتماعي امس مع نظيره الصيني جيمنج انه ما
ناقش الحرب وقعدت تاكيد على اعتقادهما
المشترك بان استخدام او حتى التلويح
باستخدام الاسلحه النوويه غير مقبول على
الاطلاق في اشاره الى تهديدات موسكو
المبطنه باستخدام اسلحه ذريه مع تراجعي
غزوها لاوكرانيا
من بالي مفتده العربيه ناديه البلبيسي
لنسالها همم عن همم اهم
يمكن تاكيده بانه تم الاتفاق عليه فيما
يتعلق بالبيان الختامي وكيف تمت تذليل
العقبات المتعلقه بلعبه المصطلحات التي
كانت روسيا سترفضها
طاهر ان اتحدث مع مسؤول امريكي رفيع
المستوى هنا على همش هذه القمه قال لي
بانه الولايات المتحده لم تكن تسعى الى ان
تكون هناك ربما ادانه مباشره بمعنى بانها
لم تطلب من دول قاده مجموعه ال 20 ان تقول
نادين بصريح العباره الغزو الروسي
لاوكرانيه لكن تحدث طبعا عن المطالبات
بالانسحاب تحدثت عن تاثير هذا الغزو على
الامن الغذائي على هشاشه الاقتصاد العالمي
لكن الموقف الروسي محرج الان لانه الاتفاق
على المسوده اتى قبل اطلاق هذه الصواريخ
على العاصمه كيف وعلى مدن اخرى وايضا هناك
تقارير اخرى تشير الى ان روسيا كانت تخطط
للانسحاب من خرسون لكنها كانت تنتظر الى
بعض نتائج الانتخابات الامريكيه حتى لا
تعطي فوزا بين قوسين للرئيس اذا الموقف
الروسي ربما اصبح محرج نوعا ما همم كما
تعرف الاتفاق على المسوده كان قبل ساعات
وقبل صدور هذه الاخبار العاجله لكن بشكل
عام كما ذكرت قاعده الدول هنا
لايجاد حلول لمشاكل مستعصيه منها طبعا
التضخم الكساد ال- اا وضع الدمى الدول
الناميه مساعدتهم للخروج من الفقر اعاده
هيكله الديون البيئه تغيير المناخيه
وبالتالي هي اجنده بامتياز اقتصاديه لكن
الحرب اوكرانيا تلقي بظلالها على هذه
القمه وخصوصا الان ونحن نتحدث عن صواريخ
تطال المدنيين لدرجه بان مستشار الامن
القومي اصدر بيان شديد اللهجه قبل قليل
وقال بان الولايات المتحده ستستمر في
دعمها لاوكرانيا سواء كان عسكري او
اقتصادي وقال ايضا بان ما فعلت روسيا
الليله سيؤدي الى قلق عميق ويجب ان يؤدي
الى قلق عميق داخل همم طبعا هذه القمه
وبين المشاركين لهذه القمه والصلاه العالم
الكبيره بعيدا اداره الخ او الازمات فقط
هل يمكن القول بانه في انجازات استطاعت
القمه همم الوصول الى سقفها على الاقل لكي
يعني يعرف العالم كيف على الاقل يبدا
بمعالجتها همم مثل القضايا التي تهم
العالم اجمع وليس اقاليم محدده
بدون اد مشاكل يعني هناك اتفاق مثلا بالشق
السياسي على عدم استخدام الاسلحه النوويه
ان هذا الامر غير مقبول وكما ذكرت هذا كان
جزء من لقاء رئيس جيجي بيه همم ايضا كوريا
الشماليه وتهديها تهديداتها المستمره
لليابان وكوريا الجنوبيه هذه من ناحيه الى
هناك اتفاق على همم تحريم استخدام الاسلحه
النوويه لكن ايضا بالنسبه للانجازات
الاخرى على مستوى الاقتصاد هناك العديد من
الانجازات في الواقعه اذا نظرنا الى
البيان الذي صدر من البيت الابيض هناك
الحديث عن استثمار بمليارات الدولارات
سواء كانت بالاستثمارات الرقميه بالمشاريع
الصحيه بالانتقال حتى هنا في داخل
الاندونيسيا من استخدام ربما ال- همم
المواد النفطيه الصخريه همم لتوليد
الكهرباء طبعا واستبدالها بطاقه نظيفه
استخدام همم الاشعه الشمسيه
وغير يوم هناك ايضا مشاريع بيئيه لكن
الفكره من وراها طبعا هيكله الديون للدول
الناميه والدول الفقيره مثل تشاد وغيرها
ومشاريع اخرى في الدول في المحيط الهادي
والهندي نعم لكن طاهر كما تعرف هذا هو
تعبير للقمه القادمه في الهند واعتقد بان
قاده الدول العشرين مجموعه ال 20 نجحوا
الى حد ما في وضع خريطه الطريق ومتابعه كل
هذه المشاريع وتنفيذ لحد ما قبل ان نصل
الى القمه القادمه واحنا نتحدث على ان
سكان الكره الارضيه وصلوا اليوم الى
ثمانيه مليارات اذا انت تحدي جديد لكل هذه
الدول
الميدانيه دائما التي تحدد الكثير من
الخطوات السياسيه همم ناديه كما نعرف شكرا
جزيلا لكن نحن سنشاهد هذه الصور الاوليه
التي وصلتنا من الحدود الاوكرانيه
البولنديه لسقوط همم الصاروخين اللذين
تحدثنا عن سقوطهما اذا همم في همم عن
الصواريخ الروسيه التي سقط في بولندا
وقتلت شخصين همم وهناك اجتماع عاجل
للحكومه ولجنه الامن القومي والدفاع بعد
سقوط هذه الصواريخ الروسيه اذا المتحدث
باسم الحكومه البولنديه كما قال بانه
صواريخ الروسيه اصابت منطقه قريبه من
الحدود مع اوكرانيا وهذه هي اذن الصور
الاوليه لحسام بعض صواريخ التي سقطت
ولضرار التي تسببت بها هذه الصواريخ في
المنطقه التي سقطت فيها صواريخ الروسيه
على الحدود الاوكرانيه البورلانديه سنرى
اي معطيات سيغيرها سقوط هذه الصواريخ
الروسيه على الاراضي همم بولنديه بعد ان
تسبب همم
يعني بعد ان تسببت صواريخ روسيه ايضا من
قطاع الكهرباء في مولدوفا همم اليوم همم
واضافه الى الكثير من الاخبار التي تريدنا
حاليا عن الحكومه البولنديه التي تعقد
اجتماعا اذا همم في ال 20 جرانيتش على راس
الساعه من المفترض بعد اقل من ساعه من
الان وفقا لوك الانباء المملوكه للدوله
اضافه الى او وكاله الانباء الرسميه
بالاحرى
وهناك معلومات ايضا عن ترانس نفط الروسيه
تتحدث عن انه ابلغت من اوكرانيا بانهدادات
الغاز الى هنغاريا من خلال خط انابيب
دروجبا سيتوقف مؤقتا همم يعني هذا خبر
ايضا متعلق بازمه الغاز التي نتحدث عنها
يوميا في اوروبا الحرب على اوكرانيا
واخطارها كانت حاضره في بالي كذلك وفي
انقره ايضا او بالاحرى حظر استخدام النووي
الذي كان محورا اساسيا في لقاء
الاستخبارات الامريكيه الروسيه اللقاء جمع
مدير وكاله الاستخبارات المركزيه
الامريكيه سي اي اي واليابانز بنظره مدير
اداره الاستخبارات الروسيه الخارجيه
سرجينا في تركيا
رساله الى نظيره الروسي تتعلق بالتحذير من
عواقب استخدام اسلحه نوويه في اوكرانيا
ومخاطر تصعيد على الاستقرار الاسترات
العالمي وفق ما افادت به صحيفه وستين
جورنال الصحيفه نقلت عن المتحدث باسم مجلس
الامن القومي في البيت الابيض ان برنس حضر
نارشين بشان عواقب استخدام روسيا للاسلحه
النوويه في اوكرانيا وذلك في اطار جهود
الاداره الامريكيه للحد من خطر تصعيد
الحرب
لكن اللقاء لم يكن محاوله للتفاوض مع
موسكو حول انهاء الحرب بل ان المسؤولين
الامريكيين اصروا على انهم لن يجروا
محادثات سلام دون مشاركه الحكومه
الاوكرانيه
بحسب صحيفه نيويورك تايمز الخلاف برز حول
من طلب الاجتماع وكاله الانباء التركيه
وكاله انباء الاناضول نقلت عن مسؤولين في
الاستخبارات قولهم انا برنس كين التقيا في
انقره بدعوه من وكاله الاستخبارات الوطنيه
التركيه بينما اكد المتحدث باسم الكرام
لندن لوكاله الانباء الروسيه تاس ان
محادثات بين مسؤولين روسيا امريكيين جاءت
بمبادره من الجانب الامريكي رافضا الكشف
عن محتوىها
[موسيقى]
الفن
يقول لا يمكننا التعليق على الان على سقوط
صاروخان روسيين على بولندا المتحدث باسمه
الان اذا تحدث مباشره ويقول لا يمكننا
التعليق لا يزال الوقت مبكرا على ما يبدو
بالنسبه وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه
هناك اذن اخبار عن صاروخين روسيين بالفعل
يستقر في بولندا على الاراضي
البولنديه ولكن لا معلومات اضافيه على ما
يبدو الحكومه البولنديه
ستعقد اجتماعا لها وللجنه الامن القومي
والدفاع بعد سقوط هذين الصاروخين اذا رئيس
الوزراء يدعو الاجتماع عاجل للجنه الدفاع
الوطني وسط التقارير عن سقوط همم الصواريخ
الروسيه هناك تضارب بعد هذه الصواريخ في
الواقع
انتظار المزيد من المعلومات
وبانتظار ايضا ما سيصدر عن الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه في هذا الاطار لانه
موقفها سيكون مهما جدا في اطار امكانيات
تمدد هذا الصراع الى دول الجوار او التمكن
في اللحظات الاخيره من ضبطوا همم يعني عدم
تجاوز هذه الحرب الحدود الاوكرانيه همم
لها هناك بيلاروسيا كان جزء من هذه الحرب
في فتره بولندا ايضا وعدد من دول الجوار
نرى في جانب من الصوره الاضرار والاثار
التي همم خلفها سقوط هذه الصواريخ الروسيه
على الاراضي البولنديه همم يعني سنرى ايضا
همم التعليق الروسي على ذلك ما الذي
سيقوله الروس لانه سيكون مهما ايضا هل همم
سيعتبر بانه
ضرب لشحنات عسكريه مثلا لهدف محدد او يعني
عن طريق الخطا لانه هذا سيحدد الكثير من
الراهبات الفعل بدون شك الباحث في
العلاقات الدوليه دكتور محمد سيف الدين من
باريس اهلا بك معنا الى اي مدى ترك تصعيدا
خطيرا او يمكن احتوائه من سقوط الصواريخ
الروسيه على بولندا
بدايه لابد من توفر معطيات اضافيه حتى
نعلم يعني المعطيات المرتبطه بهذا الحدث
اذا كان ما اشارتهم اليه هو يعني مفيد جدا
في هذا السياق يجب ان نعرف هل تم بالفعل
قصف اراده بولنديه او ان الموضوع عن طريق
الخطا او انه هناك قصف لمنطقه حدوديه وليس
للاراضي في داخل البولندي يعني ننتظر الان
موقفا الموقف الامريكي والموقف الروسي
لتحديد ما هي الحدث وابعاده والقطر التي
يجب تحليله همم من ضمنها اذا كانت روسيا
قد قصفت بالفعل منطقه بولنديه داخل الحدود
البولنديه هذا له ابعاد مختلفه عن ان يكون
هذا الامر عن طريق الخطا بالمحصله يعني
وبقراءه سابقه لهذا الحدث والمصلحه
الولايات المتحده في هذه اللحظه عن تطلق
المسار السياسي في الازمه الاوكرانيه لان
لمجموعه من الاسباب يمكن انه نعددها الان
ولا اعتقد ان من مصلحه موسكو بنفس الدرجه
ان يطلق اسعار السياسي في هذه اللحظه ما
تمام ما فعلته الولايات المتحده والتحالف
الغربي في الاشهر الماضيه خصوصا يعني منذ
شباط الماضي وصعوضا هو انها استخدمت وهذه
مخاطره كبيره كانت استخدمت العقوبات بحدها
الاقصى تقريبا وذهبت بعيدا جدا في معاقبه
روسيا وهذا الامر ادى الى تقليص الوسائل
التي يمكن يعني محاسبه او الضغط على روسيا
بها في الاشهر الاخبار
نائب رئيس الوزراء الان يقول ايضا بانه
يؤكد سقوط هذه الصواريخ الروسيه همم في
بولندا اضافه الى المتحدث باسم الحكومه
البولنديه التي الذي يتحدث عن وضع متازم
كما يصفه بعد سقوط الصواريخ الروسيه على
اراضينا همم والفانتاكون يضيف نتعامل
بجديه مع التقارير بشان سقوط صاروخين
روسيين على همم بولندا همم اذا همم هناك
ايضا همم النائب رئيس الوزراء في لاتفيا
يرسل تعزيه همم الى
بولندا في ما يتعلق بهذا الموضوع ليس هناك
الكثير من المعلومات عن الخسائر
البشريه ان كان هناك خسائر او بشريه بعد
سقوط هذه الصواريخ ام لا بانتظار المزيد
من المعلومات ولكن يبدو انه العالم همم
كنا تحدثنا عن همم قتل الاثنين فعلا ولكن
لا نعرف اذا كان هناك جرحه او حجم الخسائر
الاضرار الماديه اذا بالفعل رسائل التعزيه
من نائب رئيس الوزراء همم
بولندا بسبب همم قتل هذين الصاروخان
الاثنين همم يعني غير محددي الجنسيه حتى
لست ادري اذا كانوا بولنديين ام لا اذا
همم هذه الاخبار تريدنا من بولندا بولندا
عكر دار حلف وارسو سابقا وعقر ضار همم نقل
الاسلحه الى اوكرانيا من الجانب الغربي
ومن النيتو في همم الوقت الحالي يعني
لسخريات القدر ربما همم نتابع عدم المؤتمر
الصحفي للبنتاجون الذي لا يزال يتحدث عن
التعامل بجديه مع هذه الانباء ولكن دون
اعطاء تفاصيل لانه قال لا يمكننا التعليق
الان على ذلك ولكن بالتزامن ايضا مع
الاخبار التي تتحدث عن همم عقد الحكومه
البولنديه الاجتماع همم بعد قليل سنعرف
تفاصيله واضحون تماما بشان الدفاع عن
اراضي الناتو يقول البنتاجون ده هناك
الكثير من التساؤلات لدى الجميع الان كما
قلنا بخصوص اذا ما كان همم هذا يعتبر
انذارا لاننيتو لكي يتحرك للدفاع عن همم
بعد ما طالتها الاهداف الروسيه همم ام لا
كيف سيعالج هذا الموقف خاصه
مع الكثير همم من النقاط واعود اليك دكتور
محمد الكثير من النقاط التي باتت في
الايام الاخيره همم تدل البعض على انه قد
يكون هناك بعض الليونه او المرونه سميها
ما شئت همم من قبل الطرفين ان كان من
الجانب الامريكي او الروسي والادله التي
يستخدمونها بعض ما حصل في بالي همم يعني
نقلت الاخبار انا لابروف ظل جالسا مكانه
عندما تحدث زينسكي ولم ينسحب همم قالت
الاخبار ايضا انه روسيا وافقت على الكثير
من المصطلحات التي لم يكن متوقعا ان توافق
عليها في البيان الختامي اضافه الى اللقاء
الاستخبارات في تركيا بين الطرفين ما رايك
اعتقد ان روسيا يعني سوف تواصل موقفها
لموقفها ال ال المستمر وهو الترحيب
بالمسار السياسي واعلن هذا الامر باللغه
الدبلوماسيه والقول بانها من مصلحتها ومن
يعني من ارادتها بانها تريد ان تنهي هذه
الحرب وانها تؤيد الحل السلم لكن المشكله
هي باختلاف الاولويات وباختلاف التعاريف
لموضوع الحل السلمي وعند اي حدود يجب ان
يتم رسم خط الحدود
هناك
مباشره مع الترجمه
وستات اخر معلومات كما تخص التقييم اييي
ساحه المعركه مع ايرون هو وصل هناك
والحوارات بعد كذا تتركز على نقاشات جاده
حاول احتياجات اوكرانيا الامنيه فبعد
نتائج اجتماع مجموعات الاتصال
مخرجاته ولكن النقاشات ستكون جيده
للتواصل مع شركائنا الاوكرانيين للتعرف
على افضل السبب اللي دعمهم في حربهم
المستمره ضد الاعتداء الروسي
متابعه على ذلك
عندما حصل اخر اجتماع لمجموعه الاتصال
الاولويه كانت الدفاع الجوي هل يزال ذلك
هو الحاله الان وما هو الشيء الرئيسي الذي
تسع الولايات المتحده من الاجتماع
المهاجمين
المضاده هو اليوم وبعد ضربته روسيا الجويه
والصاروخيه ضد الاهداف المدنيه في مناطقه
مثلكيه بس فان الدفاع الجوي يبقى اولويات
وسوف يستمر بالعمل مع اوكرانيا
لدعمهم من وجهه نظر الدفاع الجوي ولكنه
مرحله الشتاء قادمه وسنناقش جوانب اخرى
فيما يخصه انواع الدعم التي يمكن انه
يقدمه
لقدراتهم البريه
والطقس البارد او كذلك
لمعالجهمهم من ناحيه البناء التحتيه
الخاصه بالطاقه
الرياض
الذخيره الى روسيا وان كان جواب نعم هل هي
تنقل اشياء اخرى الى جانب الذخيره
واهل ذلك فقط عبر
شمال افريقيا وشرق الاوسط
معلومات
كوريا الشماليه
التاسعه لتوفير تلك الذخيره بشكل سريع عبر
شمال افريقيا والشرق الاوسط ولكن في هذه
المرحله هذه كل المعلومات التي يمكنني ان
اقدمها لكم هو هل اي من حلف انا مستعد
لوقفه عمليات النقل هذه سؤال وجيه ولكن
الى ودنا نتحدث نيابه عن حلفائنا هذا
الشيء سوف نستمر بمراجعاته عن كتب
اذا نكتفي بهذا القدر
فيما يتعلق همم
سقوط الصواريخ الروسيه على الاراضي
البولنديه واتابع مع البحث في العلاقات
الدوليه من باريس دكتور محمد همم سيف
الدين دكتور محمد بناء يعني يعني قطعت
فكرتها قبل قليل بسبب النقل المباشر ولكن
ما الذي كنت تريد اليه من خلال تحليلي
فيما يتعلق باستشراف كلمه وقادم على صعيد
الحرب الاوكرانيه اخدا بعين الاعتبار
المعطيات السابقه لهذه الاخبار العاجله اي
بمعنى ان لم تغير في سياق الاحداث
يعني بالتاكيد هذا الحدث سوف يؤدي الى
زياده الضغوط على الروسيه وسوف يستعمل في
هذا السياق السياق السابقين يعني كان
محاوله الاستفاده من الاحداث في خيرسون
الان يعني اعلن اعلن الناتو في الاسابيع
الماضيه عن جهوزيه بطاريات الدفاع الجوي
بالنسبه له فيما يتعلق بالمخاطر المتاتيه
من من روسيا ومن توسع هذا او احتمالات
توسع هذا النزاع لكن الان مثلا موضوع سقوط
صواريخ في في بولندا يجب ان يطرح تساؤل
مهمه هي الدفاعاته اين يعني لماذا لم
تتحرك في حال كانت هذه الصواريخ الاتيه من
روسيا همم بالاضافه الى ذلك لماذا في هذه
اللحظه تحديدا في لحظه اجتماع قمه العشرين
في لحظه اجتماع القيادات الامنيه من
المخابرات الامريكيه ومن المخابرات
الروسيه لماذا في لحظه بدء الشتاء وتعطل
العمليه العسكريه والتالي انتفاء بنسبه
عاليه انتفاء قدره اي من الطرفين على
التقدم على مساحات واسعه في الميدان
وبالتالي
يجب ان يؤخذ هذا الحدث طبعا لهذه المعطيات
في سياق الضغوطات المستمره لاطلاق المسار
السياسي ومحاوله الوصول الى حل قبل الوصول
الى الربيع المقبل لان المرحله الفاصله من
الان وحتى الربيع المقبل سوف تشهد يعني
معطيات مختلفه وجديده تماما منها من احد
هذه المعطيات المهمه جدا هو دخول قوات
جديده في التعبئه عند الطرف الروسي هو
يعني استمرار التفاعلات المرتبطه بالازمه
الاقتصاديه الكبيره جدا في الغرب تحديدا
ازمه التضخم وما يتحدثون عنه اليوم في قمه
العشرين وهو ازمه الديون المقبله وهي
تتوقع ان تنفجر في عام 2018 اذا تحدثنا
على المسار الاقتصادي وما سوف يحدثه من
تفاعلات في الازمه الاوكرانيه اعتقد ان
مصلحه التحالف الغربي الان الوصول الى
يعني حال في ما يتعلق بالازمه الاخرانيه
لا شك ان هذا الحدث المستجد الان سوف
يستخدم في هذا السياق وكنا نتحدث قبل يعني
قبل المؤتمر الصحفي للفنتاج وانا عن
الموضوع ان اللغه الدبلوماسيه منفصله بشكل
تام في هذه اللحظه عن الضرورات والاولويات
لاي من الطرفين لان اللغه الدبلوماسيه
بالطبع سوف تشير الى رفض استخدام الاسلحه
النوويه والى ضروره التواصل الى حال سلمي
وضروره وقف الحرب كل هذا مفهوم حتى في
الموضوعات المختلفه يعني المتعلقه بالمناخ
والمتعلقه بالمكافحه الاوبئه وغير ذلك كل
هذا يعني هناك بروتوكولات وهناك يعني همم
بهذا الاطار الدول الطوافيه حول يعني بس
الميدان هو الذي يقرر النتيجه بدون شك
ومعطياته شكرا جزيلا لك دكتور محمد سيف
الدين الباحث في العلاقه الدوليه من باريس
وانذكر بانه وكاله الانباء البولنديه
افادت انا الرئيس سكي دعى الاجتماع الدفاع
الوطني وسط همم هذا هذه التقارير عن سقوط
صاروخ روسي على الاراضي البولنديه يقول
انه لا يزال يتحقق من ذلك وهمم يعني لا
وقت تعليق بالمزيد حول هذا الموضوع ولكن
يؤكد الوضوح وضوح الولايات المتحده
والناتو فيما يتعلق بحمايه اراضي حلف
شمالي الاطلسي من اكياف الان العاصمه
الاوكرانيه مراسل العربيه حذيفه عادل
يطلعنا على الاوضاع الامنيه والميدانيه
هناك خاصه بعد ما حصل اليوم وكل الاضرار
التي تركتها الصواريخ الروسيه ليس فقط في
اوكرانيا على ما بدلنا الان انما ايضا في
دول الجوار حذيفه
تحياتي طاهر يعني ابدا بدول الجوار
صاروخين سقطاه في قريه قريبه من الحدود
الاوكرانيه قتل شخصين وطبعا اوكرانيا ايضا
ارسلت التعازي وايضا التضامن مع دوله
بولندا على لسان الخارجيه الاوكرانيه اما
هنا في اوكرانيا فسبعه ملايين مواطن دون
كهرباء في هذه اللحظات طاهر في مدن
وولايات مختلفه تم اطلاق 100 صاروخ
استطاعت استطاع الدفاع الجوي الاوكراني ان
يسقط عدد كبير من هذه الصواريخ ولكن البعض
منها استطاع ان يصل الى اهداف في بعض
المدن هنالك خمسه عشر محطه للكهرباء اصيبت
جراء هذا القصف الكبير والواسع واسع
النطاق في ولايات اوكرانيا المختلفه همم
طبعا همم القصف يعني تضر بشكل كبير
الولايات الشمال وولايات الوسط في
اوكرانيا طبعا اصيبه البنيه التحتيه همم
الطاقه طبعا همم الولايات التي تضررت بشكل
كبير هي العاصمه الاوكرانيه كيف كذلك لفوق
والشر نفسي وايضا
على المنطقه منطقه كليبات وادي لبرا بطرس
واوديسه وبلطافا وخارقه حتى هذه اللحظه
90% من همم الفولت هي دوره كهرباء وكذلك
80% من درب التروس واخاكف بالكامل انقطعت
عنها الكهرباء العاصمه كيف عدد كبير من
احياء العاصمه دون كهرباء اداره الكهرباء
شركه الكهرباء قالت انه منذ الان وحتى
اشعار اخر لم تكون همم الجداول التي تم
اصدارها للمواطنين فعاله سوف يتم قطع
الكهرباء بشكل كبير ستزيد ساعات قطوعات
الكهرباء نسبه للضرر الكبير الذي اصابع
التحتيه طلب من المواطنين طبعا يعني
تفاهموا الوضع وان همم يتعاونوا ان يبداوا
في ترشيد الكهرباء وبالتاكيد ان يصبر على
هذه الظروف الرئيس يعني ارسل رساله همم
مقتضمه جدا قال فيها يجب ان نتخطى الامر
ان روسيا تريد كسر عزيمه الاوكرانيين ولكن
يجب ان نتخطى كل ذلك
العربيه من كيف شكرا جزيلا على كل هذه
الاحاطه ونحن بانتظار بيان من البيت
الابيض ايضا فيما يتعلق بسقوط الصواريخ اا
الروسيه على همم بولندا وفقا لما تفيد به
ناديه البلبيسي همم مراسله العربيه في
واشنطن المفردات العربيه الان الى بالي
حيث يتوقع ان يلتقي الرئيس وزراء بريطانيا
خلال همم ساعه ابلغت مولدوفا عن انقطاعات
هائله للكهرباء في انحاء البلاد بعد غارات
عسكريه روسيه على البنيه التحتيه للطاقه
في اوكرانيا والتي اسقطت خطا مهما
للكهرباء يمد الدوله بطاقتها وقال وزير
البنيه التحتيه في مولدوفا في بيان بعد
قصف روسيا لنظام الطاقه الاوكراني انقطع
احد خطوط الطاقه الذي يامن انتقال
الكهرباء الى بلادنا وادى ذلك الى
انقطاعات هائله للكهرباء في انحاء البلاد
واشار الى ان خطوط الطاقه التي اسقطت لم
تتضرر وان من قطع التلقائيا كاجراء للامام
واضاف ان شركه المزوده تعمل على استعاده
الكهرباء موضحا انه سيتم ابلاغ المواطنين
في مولدوفا بالتحديثات اللازمه
هذا واكدت رئاسه الاوكرانيه ان اكثر من
سبعه ملايين منزل اوكراني محروم من
الكهرباء كما افاد قبل قليل حذيفه عادل
بعد ضربات روسيه جديده استهدفت شبكه
الكهرباء في البلاد فيما اعلن الرئيس
الاوكراني بعد استهداف في بلاده بوابل من
الصواريخ الروسيه انا موسكو لن تحقق هدفها
بتدمير البنيه التحتيه للطاقه الاوكرانيه
اكثر من 100 صاروخ اطلقتها روسيا على
العاصمه الاوكرانيه كيف ومدن اخرى اصابت
عدد من البناء التحتيه الرئيسيه للطاقه
وفق ما اعلن سلاح الجو الاوكراني
امتدت اثار القصف الى خط مهم للكهرباء يمد
بالطاقه الدوله المجاوره مولدوفا والتي
اعلنت عن انقطاعات هائله للكهرباء في
انحاء البلاد بعد قصف روسيا لنظام الطاقه
الاوكراني في الساعه الماضيه انقطع احد
خطوط الطاقه الذي يؤمن انتقال الكهربائي
الى بلادنا وعدد ذلك الى انقطاعات هائله
الكهرباء في انحاء البلاد
دوي الانفجارات كان قد سمع في العاصمه
الاوكرانيه كيف غربا وفي مدينه خارجي في
شمال شرق البلاد وعقبه ضربات الجويه
انقطعت الكهرباء في العديد من المناطق
وفقما قالت السلطات الاوكرانيه
كما تسبب بوابل الصواريخ الروسيه على
مناطق اوكرانيا باندلاع الحرائق في عده
مباني سكنيه وبتدمير البنيه التحتيه
للطاقه الاخرانيه وفق اعلان الرئيس
الاوكراني بولودي ميرسي
يطلقوا 85 ضربه صاروخيه على اوكرانيا وعلى
مدننا في الغالب على البنيه التحتيه
للطاقه من الواضح هذا ما يريده العدو ولن
يحققه هدفهما ربما لا تنزله هناك ضربات في
المستقبل لذلك اطلب من الجميع توخي الحذر
والبقاء في الملاجيء لفتره من الوقت اعلم
ان الضربات قطعت امدادات الكهرباء عن
العديد من المدن في بلدنا نحن نعمل وسوف
نستعد كل شيء وسوف ننجو من كل شيء
وداع عمده خاركيب السكان للبقاء في
الملاجئ فيما اعلنت شبكه النت بلوكس عن
اضطراب كبير في خدمه الانترنت في اوكرانيا
بعد الهجمات يشار الى ان الضربات
الصاروخيه الروسيه اتت فيما يستمر القتال
شرقا بين القوات الروسيه والاكرانيه كما
اتت بعد ايام على الانسحاب من غير سنجوبه
وفي خضم عقاد قمه مجموعه العشرين في
اندونيسيا
مصطفى
الديمقراطي اهلا بكم معنا استاذ مصطفى
اسمح لنا بدنا نغير الموضوع نستفيد من
وجودك معنا لنقرا في الاخبار العاجله
الوارده عن استهداف صواريخ روسيه بولندا
بغض النظر عن ما اذا كان ذلك قد جاء عن
طريق الخطا او تعمدا كيف تقرا امكانيه
تحرك دول النيته همم للرد على ما حصل
مساء الخير طبعا بالتاكيد هذا يعني خبر
جدا مؤسف بما انه هناك العديد يحاولون
هناك ايضا دعم عندكم مفاوضات دعم ان يكون
هناك نهايه للحرب لكن اعتقد ان هذا ما حصل
قبل تقريبا بعد دقائق وتصعيد لهذه الازمه
وبالتاكيد انه هذا الموضوع هو يكون تحت
الغطاء الماده الخامسه من الناتو اي عضو
من اعضاء الناتو يتعرض الى هجمات يجب ان
يكون هناك الرد بالاجماع لكن لحد الان هذه
النقطه يعني تعتقد انه هناك من اراد ان
يصعد بغض النظر بدون تحميل الجهه
المسؤوليه ولكن هناك من اراد ان يصعد في
هذه الحرب لانه هناك الكثير من البوادر
الايجابيه
طبعا احنا مثل ما شاهدنا حتى اليوم السيد
قال انه نحن نسعى ان يكون هناك حوار لكن
روسي لا تريد هذا الشيء واعتقد انه ما حصل
الان هو هذا التصعيد
لهذه الحرب
الهمجيه لكن اعتقد انه ما حصل قبل دقائق
قليله سوف يقوم فعلا بتشغيل كبير لان الان
هو الموضوع تحدي خطوط الناتو واعتقد ان
هذه ازمه جدا كبيره لا اعرف التي وصلته
من قبل الناس ولكن مثل ما اخبرتك همم اي
بلد او عضو في الناتو حسب المعاهده من
المواد الخامس تنص انه يجب ان يكون هناك
رد بالا
هذا صحيح خصا مع يعني مع ما ذكرت وحضرتك
ايضا اضاف ذا لينسكي مشبها ما حصل
بين انسحاب روسيا من خيرسون بانزال
الحلفاء في الاورماندي وهو الذي غير مسار
الحرب تماما همم الحرب العالميه الثانيه
اذا عندما يتحدث بهذه اللهجه وعندما يجتمع
رئيس مخابرات امريكا مع رئيس مخابرات
عسكريه روسيه في تركيا مع كل الاشارات
التي رايناها في بالي كذلك تكون الامور
باتت مجهز اكثر لشيء ماء ولكن ما سقفه
باعتقادك استاذ مصطفى الذي يمكن ان تقبل
به دول الغرب واوكرانيا وكذلك روسيا لك
لكي يتم الاتفاق عليه
اعتقد انه هو الان يعني لماذا بهذا
التوقيت لماذا في قمه العشرين لماذا عندما
يجتمع الجميع الان مجتمع هناك في بالي
لايجاد حلول ومتفق بان هذه الحربيه لا احد
يريدها ان يكون هذا العرض 19 دوله موجوده
لا تريد ان تكون الاستمراريه لهذه الحرب
لماذا التوقيت الان حاصل لماذا الان
استهدف ايضا بولندا بهذا الشكل مثل ما مثل
ما يعلم الجميع عن الجميع قال انه يريد ان
هناك نهايه الى هذه الحرب الدمويه لكن
اعتقد ما حصل قبل دقائق هذا سوف يقوم
بتصيدات للعديد من الملفات وايضا نعتقد
انه سوف يكون هناك رد ايضا لكن لا اعتقد
انه الان بولندا ايضا الان تريد ان تظهر
يعني قوتها وتريد
وزير الخارج
بانه الاخبار الاتيه من بولندا مقلقه
للغايه وانا استوني جاهزه للدفاع عن كل
شبر من اراضي همم
في تغريده له على تويتر تنقلها رويترز
يبدو ان الموضوع بالنسبه الى كل دول جوار
اوكرانيا غير عادي ويستوجب الاستغفار على
الاقل
بالتاكيد طبعا تذكرتها قبل قليل بسؤالك
لكن عندما هناك انسحاب روسي البعظه
والعديد من الدول هي رحبت بهذا الموضوع
بانه فعلا روسيا تريد ان يكون هناك انت
فاضي يريدين اكون كيدنا والجميع ايضا قال
ان هذا بوادر جيده لكن ما حصل الان اعتقد
هي بوادر الرئيس جيده ولكن كانت عباره عن
نوايا مبيته لانكم مثل هذا التصعيد والذي
نحن لا نريده لكن الان مثل ما تعرف همم
الناتجه يدافع عن كل شبر من اعضاءه ان
يكون هناك اذا الرد لكن بالبدايه
ان ابتعد عن التكهنات لان انا لا اعرف
ماذا سوف يحصل ساعات القريبه القادمه لكن
نتمنى ان يكون هناك ايضا فعلا يعني حل
نهائي لهذه الازمه لكن لا اجد هذا في
الافق طبعا يعني
استونيا تضامنهما بالتالي مع بولندا بعد
سقوط صواريخ روسيه عليها دول البلطيق من
اكثر الدول تخوفا وتوجه ساند منذ بدايه
الحرب
الروسيه على اوكرانيا شكرا جزيلا لك استاذ
مصطفى العمار مجلس ومنى حس بالاتحاد
المسيحي الديمقراطيه من برلين تحياتي اليه
نحن بقونا معكم لانه متابعه ايضا في
العربيه 360 جرام بيستعد الليله للاعلام
عن ترشحه للانتخابات الرئاسيه الامريكيه
للمره الثالثه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد من المتوقع ان يعلن
اليوم الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد
ترامب رسميا ترشحه للانتخابات الرئاسيه
لعام 2024 رافضا بذلك دعوات من جمهوريين
بالتراجع بعد ما جاءت نتائج الانتخابات
منتصف الولايه غير مرضيه للحزبه وقال جيش
احد مستشار ترامب ان الرئيس السابق سيعلن
ترشحه للانتخابات الرئاسيه لافتا الى ان
اعلان ترامب سيكون احترافيه جدا ومتحفضا
جدا ينظر الى اعلان الثلاثاء هذا على انه
فرصه لترامب لتحطيم فرصيا من منافسه
المحتملين بمن فيهم روندي سانتس اضافه الى
نائبه السابق الذي ينشر مذكراته في اليوم
نفسه
نتابع واياكم اذا في هذا الموضوع من
فلوريدا مع مراسله العربيه ريتا سليمان
اهلا بك معنا ريتا ما المتوقع عندك من
خطاب ترامب خاصه لجهه الطريقه لانه هو
يعني معروف
بخطاب يعني بانه قد لا يتوقعه كثيرون في
افعاله وخطاباته وتصرفاته ولكن في بعض
يقولون بانه سيكون احترافيه ومتحفضا
امام امام
يعني
نترقد الاعلان الذي سيجري به الرئيس
السابق دونالد ترامب اليوم في تمام الساعه
9:00 بتوقيت المحلي همم
مستشارين ومقربين من الرئيس دونالد ترامب
اكدوا بانه سيعلن ترشحه هذا الاعلان الذي
كان منتظر من تعده ايام حقيقه نسمع به حتى
تحديدا بدانا نسمع انه سيعلن ترشحه في
اوهايو قبل ايام من الانتخابات النصفيه
عندما كان همم في همم يحسد الدعم لجدي
فانس تحديدا ولكن مستشار يهنا صحوه بان لا
يعلن ترشحه وربما انقذوه من امكانيه تعرض
لهم بسبب نتائج الانتخابات لو همم اا اعلن
ترشح للانتخابات الرئاسيه حينها همم في
همم من بعد السابع من نوفمبر تحديدا ومع
اعلان النتائج وتبين انه النتائج ليست كما
يريد الحزب الجمهوري ولا كما يريد الرئيس
دونالد ترامب لم يستطيع ترامب همم
الانسحاب من عدم اعلان ترشحه في التوقيت
الذي حددوا في الخامس عشر من نوفمبر اي
اليوم همم على الرغم من انه مستشاريه هنا
صحيح بقول لا يفعل ذلك وان يؤجل الامر حتى
انتخابات الاعاده في ولايه جورجيا ولكن
المعروف بانه يحب الاعلام ويرفض فكره
الاستسلام ويرفض فكره ان يبدو ضعيفا
وتحديدا امام الاعلام فهو الملاكم الذي لا
يقع ارضا كما يحب همم يسمي نفسه نترقب هذا
الاعلان مستشار اكدوا بانه سيعلن ترشحه
ولكن حتى اللحظه لا يمكن التنبه ابدا
بتصرفات الرئيس دونالد ترامب
في هذا الموضوع يعني يوم طويل في هذه
التغطيه وسنغطي ذلك بطبيعه حلف العربيه
لكن اقاطعك هناك الكثير من الاخبار
العاجله لتعذريني على اهميه الموضوع الذي
نتحدث فيه معك منهنغاريا فيكتور اوربن همم
يعقد مجلس الدفاع ايضا همم رئيس الوزراء
الهنغاري طبعا همم بعد ما حصل في بولندا
من سقوط الصواريخ الروسيه على بولندا اخر
الاخبار المتعلقه
بمحصل ايضا وهذه الصور ايضا همم تصلنا
وفيديوهات للاثار التي خلفتها الصواريخ
الروسيه مشاهد للاضرار في المنطقه التي
سقطت فيها الصواريخ الروسيه في بولندا اذا
هناك الكثير من الاستنفار الاوروبي همم في
بعد هذه الاخبار الكثير من القلق همم
الرؤساء الوزراء وزراء خارجيه وزراء دفاع
دول نتو همم دول الجوار اوكرانيا كلهم في
تاهب همم
يعقدون الاجتماعات الامنيه والدفاعيه على
مدار الساعه بانتظار نتائجها وبانتظار ان
ترد المزيد من المعلومات من الجانب
الامريكي ايضا والجانب الروسي كذلك او
التعليقات والمواقف اذا لم تكن هناك
معلومات
وافيه بعد ما حصل لانه البنتاجون قال لا
يزال يتحقق من هذه الاخبار وانه لا يمكنه
الادلاء بالمزيد من التعليقات حول هذا
الموضوع الا بعد توفر المعطيات اللازمه
ولكن الدول المحيطه يبدو انها قلقه جدا من
ما حصل وقد تفهمه على انه تصعيد روسي
بانتظار ما الذي ستدلي به موسكو في هذا
الاطار اذا همم كل دول الجوار الان متاهبه
للنظر في هذا الموضوع واخر الاخبار من
المجر رئيس الوزراء الهنداري اوربان يعقد
مجلس الدفاع بعد تقارير عن سقوط الصواريخ
الروسيه في بولندا وهذه اخر المشاهد
والفيديوهات التي تردنا من هناك من
المنطقه التي سقطت فيها هذه الصواريخ كنا
ذكرنا بان بولندا دعت الى اجتماع عاجل
لمجلس الامن الوطني بناءا على ما علم من
الحكومه اضافه الى تصريح وزير الخارجيه
الاستوني عن القلق البالغ بعد هذه الاخبار
وعن جهوزيه استونيا للدفاع عن كل شبر من
اراضي النيته حلف شمال الاطلسيه اذا اخبار
ليست عاديه اليوم فيما يتعلق بمصار الحرب
الروسيه الاوكرانيه بغض النظر عن كيفيه
تفسير ما حصل من قبل الروس اذا نتابع
واياكم مشاهدينا في رصد هذه الاخبار وكل
ما يرد فيها من اخبار عاجله ومن صور ومن
فيديوات
والله مش كان معنا
الروسيه بانتظار المزيد من التصريحات
والتعليقات والمواقف حول ما حصل نعود بعد
فاصل لمتابعه كل ما يحصل حول هذا الموضوع
اضافه الى مواضيع اخرى فارجو ان تتفضلوا
بالبقاء معنا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد الى مصر مستمر باثاره
الجدل في تويتر من لحظه اعلان نيه شراء
الموقع الى الاستحواذ وحتى الان جديد الى
المصري هو طرد موظف بتغريده على موقعه
تويتر لمهندس ناقشه بامور
عن بطء تطبيق تويتر في العديد من البلدان
خاصه على الهواتف العامله
المطورون لاصلاح هذا الخلل او البطئ بعد
هذا المهندس بسلسله تغريدات تشرح ما قام
به فريقه لتطوير تطبيق تويتر على اندرويد
ثم اغرد
ما الذي يمنع المدير من مناقشه تلك
المسائل عبر اجتماع مع الموظفين او برساله
عبر البريد الالكتروني الى ماسك حسن الامر
من خلال رده على تساؤل مغرد اخر سال ماسك
عن سبب قبوله بتصرف كهذا ضمن فريقه الى
الماسك غرد بكلمتين فقط انه مطرود ليتلقى
المهندس فرون هوفر اول حاله طرد داخليه في
تويتر بتغريده وكده المطور قرار الفصل
بنشر صوره لجهاز الكمبيوتر الخاص به والذي
لا يمكنه الدخول اليه يمكنه الدخول اليه
بعد قرار فصله
[موسيقى]
رئيس الوزراء التشيكي في يلا يقول انه اذا
اكدت بولندا سقوط الصواريخ الروسيه في
اراضيها فهذا سيكون
تصعيد اخر من روسيا في تغريده على تويتر
ايضا الرئيس الليتواني لديه التعليق حول
هذا الموضوع ويقول بانه يتضامن بشده مع
بولندا وانه كل شبر من اراضي النيته يجب
الدفاع عنها اخر الاخبار والتعليقات
المتعلقه بسقوط صواريخ روسيه على الاراضي
البولنديه خلال الاخبار اذا تتحدث عن
اضافه الى العوازل على الهواء
زلينسكي يقول انه ضربات الروسيه صفعه في
وجه مجموعه ال 20 المجتمع في بالي وزير
الدفاع سلوفاكي يقول ان التهور الروسي كما
يصفه همم يعني يعني يخرج عن السيطره همم
اضافه الى انه عن قلقه بلاده بشان ما حصل
في بولندا وانه سيتم استشاره الحلفاء
بخصوص هذا الموقف اضافه الى ما قالته
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه عن ان لا ضربات
وجهات الى تلك المنطقه على الحدود
الاوكرانيه البولنديه بالاسلحه الروسيه
وان كل ما يقوله الاعلام البولندي وبعض
مسؤولين همم هو مجرد استفزاز متعمد يهدف
الى تصعيد الموقف اذا هذه اخر الاخبار
المتعلقه بهذا همم الموضوع والدبلوماسي
الاوروبيه يقول رد فعل الناتو على حدث
بولندا يعتمد على تصريحات هوشه حول ملكيه
الصواريخ همم ملاحظه اخيره بعض المحللين
العسكريين امريكيين وفقا لما نقلته لناديا
البلبيسي قبل قليل مراسله العربيه من
واشنطن يتحدثون عن امكانيه ان تكون
الدفاعات الاوكرانيه قد تصدق الصواريخ
الروسيه على الاراضي الاوكرانيه ولكنها
سقطت في الاراضي البولنديه لانها محاديه
جدا هي على الحدود